are there any questions there's a
gentleman at the bank
thank you I have a question for minister
or let the be Tony I'm Chris maranello
from the art claim database and art
recovery international this morning
there's news out of Christie's where a
number of objects were pulled from sale
for having been matched with the Athena
and Giacomo Medici archives and I was
wondering what your position is what the
ministry's position is on making those
archives public so that the trade could
search and do due diligence checks
against that archive well I'd say I have
no idea what is the position of the
minister you would forgive me because we
haven't discussed about this matter but
I suppose the position of the minister
could be easily to make these archives
open I suppose
madam [ __ ] toffee Michelle Van Ryn
several of us in this room know him we
also know that you showed her the
picture of the peg Goldberg mosaics well
he sold them to her and then he told the
FBI she had them and so we made money
both ways possible tahir question to you
is I think the dealing with informants
is the right way to recover many of
these sorts of things that are stolen
looted antiquities and such but how do
you resolve the moral dilemma of dealing
with somebody like michelle van ryn who
is responsible with others for stealing
them in the first place selling them on
and then telling authorities for his own
rewards where they are he works both
sides of the street how do you how do
you deal with that moral dilemma I
actually thank you very much this
question but the destruction of cultural
heritage was very expensive and indeed
mr. for Ryan and mr. Digman were key
players in selling the artifacts Cyprus
has never cooperated in a way on the
expense of possessors every time we
found an artifact we try and negotiate
convince people to give it back because
stolen all start civil actions the fact
that the legislation is so weak that we
could not bring to justice their art
dealers is what forced me in 1997 to
speak to his beatitude at the time and
say look it is an international ring of
our traffickers that if we don't take
one to work with the authorities with
the police to set up the others we will
never get to the bottom of it and my
lord
Lema my compatriot was how can I go and
start civil case and prosecute the ones
who bought the artifacts when the
dealers are free and until today the
system allows them free even after the
Stingray in Germany the German
legislation says that if you trade
stolen treasures that you can prove you
have em in your possession for more than
10 years you are free so all those
artifacts after 18 years for civil case
last few months ago some of them came
back and the right of the traffickers
were equal to the rights of the people
of Cyprus various areas of improvement
and very well deserved a gentleman
yes
its original signatories to the campaign
with romesco 22 campaign
and it is one scene in Russia he's
guilty of saluting variability and even
home
is that also
the peoples of the record
you
well I think that this question should
be asked to them and of course I can
only share some concerns in front of the
contradictions of the behavior of some
countries which make some declaration on
one hand but maybe on the other they
behave in a different way but again the
reason why this happened should we asked
them what I think you know that it's
very difficult to refuse countries to
agree to our proposal and I just
mentioned some of these countries among
which Russia and China and other
countries I've mentioned before there
are more of them and I think it would be
difficult to say don't underline or
don't sign our proposal now I don't know
which would be the fine at least of the
country which we support our proposal
again I can see easily the contradiction
that you mention which is very clear why
this happened and why they've been
decided to support it I'll italy's
proposed there is something that may be
against to be asked to them we have two
questions here and then soviet so
we speak later on on Bosnia but I have a
question to mr. Simpson regarding
Afghanistan and the return of artifacts
like the Buddha statue are there any
precautions being taken encased Taliban
are back in power or at least it's some
sort of a power-sharing situation that
things will not repeat itself thank you
I think none of us can foretell the
future I don't think we can the
authorities in Kabul have made steps
great steps to safeguard the security of
their museum in Kabul they have built
some big blast wall outside the front
they have a permanent garrison and
they're confident enough there to open
new galleries i was there in november
and there are five or so galleries
mostly new to celebrating new
discoveries of Gondar and sculpture
which completely change our appreciation
of buddhist art in afghanistan i think
so they're confident and they're they're
the caretakers of their culture they
have learnt and this is I think a very
good lesson for everyone that it's very
important to have a good digital
inventory of your collections and so
they're working with the Oriental
Institute in Chicago to make a new
catalogue of everything that they have
with photographs and that was a very key
part of our work in terms of cataloging
material that we could identify for
sending back but we could make an
illustrated inventory and that that
inventory should be published so that if
the worst thing happens again I mean
does lightning strike twice in the same
place I don't know but it shouldn't
at least you know what actually came
from that museum and how that should be
separated from what one might call the
background noise of material that's come
out a long time before all might still
be coming out I hope that answers the
question you had a question from the
cult of cultural minister of italy you
mentioned something about war crimes
against humanity including cultural
heritage destruction I wonder if such a
case could be backdated to actually
charge simply because there is such a
charge of double standards could one go
back and actually charge bush and Blair
for their cut for what they did in Iraq
which actually has led to the beginning
of is so forth so would there be a
consideration to actually take a case
against those two for her crimes against
humanity which happened in Iraq well i
think that the subject that you open is
such a wide one that would need a very
very deep and serious confrontation my
the proposal I was bringing to this
audience was simply regarding what's
happening now in Iraq Syria and Libya
and how to face the future of these
three countries which hopefully one day
we'll be able to start again
and they will have no sign left of their
cultural identity but I agreed that the
the subject that you have raised now is
extremely important and would really
need a deep thought about it is not what
we have proposed up to now but clearly
the door is open for a confrontation on
this method can I add something to that
I'm fortunate to live in to hate where
all the war tribunals are and the
International Criminal Court for your
information there are in the statute of
icc there is room to prosecute for
cultural cleansing and also in the
tribunal formulas later however today no
prosecutor has brought to cut to justice
any criminals for cultural cleansing on
its own only in the case of former
yugoslavia the web cases in relation to
other crimes but ICC is not recognized
by all countries as we know including
the US and many other and will cause a
long way to go and normally they don't
work backwards onwards or England and
the question for Beth that applies to
all panel members I wonder if it's
useful to begin to distinguish between
activities directed out and those that
incidentally effect hmm it is
that's a really good point I think all
of us need to be mindful of the help
that legal frameworks and big boot codes
of practice can give us to our work but
this distinction between starting from
now and looking forward and dealing with
the issues that problems that we inherit
when we begin to look at a subject is a
really a really intense one right across
right across collecting collecting and
law I would say so of course we need to
look at what's intentional and what's
accidental but with the guidance that we
have from the time we are now we need to
begin by putting our house in order to
the best of our ability that gets that's
what I can say but they say the
discussion discussion is like today
we'll highlight areas of improvement and
for example the question before about
database databases there are a number of
databases and there are a number of
individuals out there and institutions
were doing marvelous work however you
will see that there are difficulties and
areas that we could work better for
example how to share databases even this
would be beneath databases and how to
harmonize legislation for cultural
heritage you will see that even within
the European Union you have different
national laws and the
time I think I guess time is nice and I
this is one of the reason why to
recuperate sometimes works of art is
very difficult because despite our
police for example can get what this
object is to get it back the difference
in legislation other countries makes it
very difficult but when there's a will
there's a way and for Cyprus there was a
week and even work with one of the
leaders and the police to bring their to
expose the problem so I think there's a
lot of willya we just have to find a way
one more question over there was
actually on that last point and we've
heard about the sort of cultural looting
and destruction that's taken place in if
you like historic conflict zones like
Bosley or in Cyprus and the fact that
much of the looted art remains very much
at large and of course this sends out a
very negative message to current
conflict zones and future conflict zones
where the cultural looting is currently
taking place and the question is
specifically this at what specific
legislative steps should be taken by
governments or international bodies to
really nail this problem it's open to
other look at once to answer thank you
cultural cleansing should be crime
against humanity and I'm looking for
brave prosecution of prosecutors who are
going to really bring these to justice
as the only way to go forward of course
there is a lot more like prevent
set around but I think okay I read
earlier that cultural heritage crime has
been with us for many years of course we
know that in this session has really
demonstrated that but the only thing
that has really changed is communication
than those crimes are now communicated
extremely quickly by those perpetrating
the crimes and by those suffering them
but maybe the thing that this session is
highlighted is that our own
communication hasn't always taken
advantage of technology we're still not
sharing the information we have with a
broad sector of the cultural community
not sharing lost data objects that have
been looted as quickly and as
efficiently as we could and maybe that's
a lesson that we can take forward and
can ask you all to join me in thanking
our speakers from the first session
you